okay so tell me this John you're going
to record when you sit down is there is
there a place a thing you start to play
that is your home you're in kenner your
is there something that gets you back
there fast
oh yeah it's funny that's the first
track on the record
yeah kinder kinder boogie in a book is
the song that I feel is one of the most
authentic ways I've approached the piano
I heard people growing up the late Henry
Butler James Booker we talked about it's
just so many great pianists who had a
style of playing that was just very
rhythmic it's almost like a band is in
their left hand alone
[Music]
it's kind of rhythm is happening and
then the right hand is like wailing you
could cry it's a beautiful it's a
beautiful celebration to start a record
that has many themes throughout when I
first heard that song I wondered how
many people are playing this song cuz it
sounds like there's so much going on
there's like four hands on the piano
how'd you get all those hands on the
piano I love creating a sense of
community even if it's just me at the
piano so I'm thinking of not just
playing the piano but I'm thinking of a
scene so this is like the party and
stuff glasses clinking people walking
through the door and then the bass and
the drums they they bring the
instruments in through the door while
they're playing you know the drummer
playing the snare
[Music]
like then it's like everybody is
shuffling it like I'm seeing scenes yeah
there are pictures that I'm trying to
convey through the song and I'm thinking
about this the the lineage but also my
experience growing up and seeing so many
communal musical celebrations how many
times have you played changed st. James
infirmary in your life
I play st. James infirmary I'd say at
least 500 times I think st. James
infirmary was one of the first songs
that I learned there's a repertoire of
New Orleans standards oh the Lhasa
little eyes a James old Eliza oh when
the saints go marching in yeah and st.
James infirmary is a blues that is a
standard if you grew up in New Orleans
and you play music you'll know it by the
time you know if you started at 11 by 12
you know that one now what that is not a
party that song no no no no no it's
heavies all right so what's what's going
through your mind when you're bringing
that kind of a heavy its traditional
it's part of where you come from but
it's also what do you what's on your
mind with that song you know that one is
uh interesting because um if you listen
to the the recording I'm thinking of the
scene of a Jazz funeral in New Orleans
there's a celebration for when you die
in the dirge that kind of thing is
happening who are you going into the
church celebration that happens
afterwards it's what we call second line
but this is the first line and I'm just
thinking of that kind of scenario and
then the band comes in that's the
trumpets
[Music]
you play what a wonderful world that
songs been played a lot you have a
different interpretation there's that
you've got that drone what's happening
there
well if you listen to music from across
the world in the history of music a
drone has purpose a drone you know
Eastern music
if you listen to our chance Gregorian
chants alter the history of the drone is
to really get you to focus and to
channel your spirituality
and even before even before the words
come in I'm asking you to channel your
spirituality in this moment and let's go
on a journey
I see trees of green can we go on that
journey and when we do you really start
to focus on the lyrics of that song
which I don't think a lot of people have
heard in that way well it is such a
well-known song it has in a way become
wallpaper it's laying everywhere it's
yeah commercials yeah oh yeah and so
what it feels like the drone is doing
you tell me if I'm crazy you're saying
we listen to this a new yeah hey focus
on this exactly in a new way
yes it listens to this anew and really
understand that we're in a world of
beauty for the things that we've done to
it and the things that we're struggling
with this is this beautiful celestial
ball in the sky it's a divine place to
be tell me about space so what space
allows you to do is to consider what
just happened thinking about the songs
in in there I guess you could say
original incarnation you can say
nice but if you put the space
[Music]
slow it down
let's think about it for a second does
not even jump into it let's think about
it for a minute is I okay
let's breathe let's take a minute
I see trees of green
in red roses too you see the very
thought of you and I forget to do the
little ordinary things that everyone
ought to do yeah it's a love song Ray
Noble mm-hmm you know
[Music]
bask in the majesty of love you know
that feeling when you really love
somebody the very thought of you
and I forget to do
tell me about don't stop so that's the
first one you released is that does that
have a first place in your mind in any
way or is it just like the other songs
what's what's happening in don't stop
don't stop is just encapsulating all of
what I think the project is about it's
about pushing past all of the things
that could stop us from believing in the
higher ideals of humanity love
generosity the fruits of the spirit the
things that make us human and divine at
the same time so these these ideas are
stated plainly in the song and it also
is a message of hope in a dark world
things that we can oftentimes use when
we lose the plot when you talk about
regaining the plot is there a song that
regains the plot for you that's the song
that I wrote when I was in a place where
I was losing the plot and success can
take you away from Nicole so you gotta
find a way to stick to it create things
that get you back there
when it comes to loving me don't stop
I know there ain't no guarantee but
stop
let's keep it shaking while we can
you don't need another man
we'll keep rolling with the plan don't
stop